hey guys it's Pete peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips and I'm gonna do a
little how-to video for the new game
candy crush jelly which should be out
any day now and we'll talk about the the
mode where you have to beat the Queen
this is a mode where we have an opponent
it's actually different from any other
game that then I know of so far and it's
really cool can be frustrating but it's
a lot of fun you make a move and then
she makes a move so that you have like a
literal opponent which is pretty nice
and you can see that the goal here when
we play her is to spread more jelly or
spread enough to Ellie to be the Queen
so this is level 4 this is the simplest
one but we got to spread enough to beat
her so looking over the board you can
see at the top we have a meter our jelly
is the dark purple and hers is the green
and you can see that right now we have
14 out of 36 so we have to spread our
jam or jelly across 36 squares to win
this sometimes it's the whole board
sometimes it's not it just you just have
to look at the meter but as we spread
ours you'll see the meter go up if she
spreads hers to cover ours then the
meter will go down and you know it can
go back and forth throughout another
thing to keep in mind here and something
that's really important is when we make
specials like I'm gonna do on my first
move I'm gonna make a fish you see up
here it says creating a special candy
will stun the boss so now I get to make
an extra move so that's always a good
thing to do pretty much always so look
for that and we can also do it in areas
that are outside of where our jam is but
in general you know whenever I you know
I spread jam that's when I wouldn't any
other one so you could see the meter
going up because I covered three more
squares still take her turn and if she
doesn't make a special then I get to go
so
let's see where we're gonna go now
there's nothing that's really jumping
out as a real power move so I'm just
gonna go ahead and set that up over
there you can make moves on her side but
it's not usually very very good idea
obviously because you don't want to
spread her color if it's a situation I
don't we don't have one yet because
they're not close to each other but if
it situation where you're making a match
and both colors are there your color
will cover hers and that goes vice-versa
for whatever she has it as well so I got
a couple of specials over here um I just
need to get a couple more the the queen
is it's somewhat predictable it can be
you know she's you know she's simple and
her choices of moves sometimes it can be
annoying because there's gonna be things
that you're gonna want her to do but
that really comes into play more in the
cupcake Karl the puffers so here this
should probably finish things up I'll be
able to make a couple more specials in a
row see and it says up here now since I
got triple stun you can see the sort of
sparkles on the outside that means that
I get a special move which this is going
to be enough to finish it anyways with
this combo but watch it'll make like a
little explosion in the area of that
match too so the triple stun will always
help you out and you can see I I cover
an up square so now I was
so it's pretty straightforward using my
I'm doing a help to some people - ready
you know one of the things that happens
is the very beginning levels are really
easy and then as you get up gets more
complicated as far as strategy goes so
I'm gonna just went ahead and skip to
level 29 this is kind of one of the
first really hard beat the Queen levels
so load that up and talk about some
different things the reason why this one
is hard is because both boards are
separate right now and so we have to
make some sort of a special in order to
get our Jam down like we can't we can't
expand our color until we do that and
since the board small and there's a
decent amount of colors on it it's
pretty hard to set things up you know we
just don't get those easy you know
choices and then there's the added
problem of she gets to move after us
below so anything we like try to set up
up here can be she can wipe it out just
by making a match underneath so so like
right here there's really not a whole
lot of them way of good moves just
looking it over so I'm just going to go
ahead and move that and then she'll make
a move and things will move around so
we'll just see
so this will be good we go that we have
a striped that we get and we can fire
that off and now that's going to take
our dam down to the bottom board and
that just gives us more more choices she
took out most of it right away
but that's the general idea of how you
want to approach it just want to you
know try to think ahead when you can
when you're playing the Queen try to
anticipate she'll make the simplest move
most of the time so try to anticipate
what she's gonna do and then if if you
can you know you're gonna want to play a
little bit of defense from time to time
but I hope that's I'm not gonna make
this a super long video so I hope that
gives you a general idea of how it works
remember about stunning her by making
specials remember about that triple stun
especially on levels that have like
coils or blockers and things that are
you know where you have to cover the
whole board that that triple stun can
really come and helpful come in handy I
should say so please like the video if
you have any questions about how to beat
the Queen
leave them in the comments make sure you
subscribe to the channel to get more
how-to with commentary videos from this
and all the other games we play and I
hope to see you soon thanks